- Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for joining us today.
So my name's Adrian Begg.
I'm a solutions architect at AWS,
helping our customers with modernization.
- Hello, everyone. I'm Dirk.
I'm also a solutions architect with AWS.
I work with software companies
on their multidimensional transformation.
- Hello, my name is Robert,
and not to bore you,
but I'm the third solutions
architect on stage.
(Robert laughing)
- All right.
- So today, we're gonna
be talking about...
Oh, apologies.
Today, we're gonna be talking
about three really important
transformation patterns,
strangler fig, sagas,
and circuit breakers.
And it doesn't really matter where you are
on your transformation journey.
Whether you're working on
a monolithic application
or maybe you started to carve
some of the components out
because that monolith is
literally keeping you up at night.
Or maybe you've moved,
and you've started to move
towards a divide-and-conquer pattern.
You have a bunch of
integrations with services
and you're integrating with
external services as well.
In the same way that you wanna be prepared
when you're on a journey,
making sure you have, for example,
a four-wheel drive to
navigate a bumpy road.
A good understanding
of different software
architecture patterns
and how those patterns can help you,
will help you face unexpected
challenges along the way.
But before we begin,
just wanna start by acknowledging
that every architecture
decision that we make
involves trade-offs.
In other words, whatever you
do, something's going to suck.
For the patterns that we're
gonna be discussing today,
this typically means trading
some kind of simplicity
in the architecture
for some kind of complexity,
but with a reason and a purpose.
What we need to do as architects
is choose the least painful option
and really focus on what's
most important to us
or our customers,
whether that be improving
customer experience,
reducing operational burden,
or increasing the agility
and evolvability of our application.
Okay, so for the purpose
of discussion today,
we're gonna have a sample use case,
and we're gonna explore
each of these patterns
and see how they can solve
each of the problems.
So, to start with, we have
our sample application.
Now, in the beginning,
it all started with three
friends and a simple idea.
We were all interested in science news,
and we were really not satisfied
with the services that were available.
We wanted something
entertaining, something engaging.
So, we sat together and we thought:
How can we solve this problem?
A couple of late nights, a lot of coffee,
a new science was born.
And in the beginning, it was
a pretty simple application.
We had a way for users to register,
we had a way for our
contributors to publish articles,
and we had a way for our users to comment
and give us some feedback.
We pushed to AWS, and we were live.
And within 24 hours, we're
getting our first feedback.
Our customers love it,
but wouldn't it be good if
we could find the articles?
Because there's no search
feature at the moment.
Now, we always knew that
this was gonna be something
that would come up fairly
early, and we thought about it,
but it just wasn't important for the MVP.
So, we organized a meeting,
we're gonna get a whiteboard,
we're gonna solve this problem.
The next day, we get into the office,
Slack notification pops
up, it's from my CTO.
"It's done."
"Sorry, what's done?"
"Search, it's implemented."
Okay?
Now, it wasn't the most
robust implementation,
but at this point in time,
the whole application's a
couple hundred lines of code.
And there's only three developers.
We can kind of understand
the whole application,
and look, it works, and our
customers are delighted.
We can always go back
and fix it later, right?
We're growing, and everything's great,
and this worked really well.
Until it didn't.
Now, we're a few years down the track
and a few problems are starting to occur.
So we've prioritized
getting new features into the application
as quickly as possible.
And as we started to grow,
we started to notice,
"Hey, our costs are starting to explode."
This really led us into a path,
where we really leaned into
our monolithic architecture.
Our original developers
have now since moved
on to greener pastures,
and they were great builders,
but they weren't great
at writing documentation.
We've got a whole bunch
of these features now
in our application, a whole
bunch of different components,
and nobody really understands
how all of these things work.
We've even got things in there
that we don't understand
what they really do.
We only know they're really important
because we changed them once
and the entire application went down.
We are not sure exactly
when this happened,
but at some point,
we went from developing new features
and focusing on our backlog
to just coming into the office every day
and constantly just seeing
what's on fire today.
Everyone's scared, fearful,
and now anytime we make a change,
we need to get approval
from every product manager.
At some point, everything
becomes a SevOne.
On top of that, as we've started to grow,
our application is just doing things
that we never really designed it to do.
We've been successful, we've grown,
but we really didn't design
for the user base that we had originally.
As I mentioned, our team's
paralyzed, fearful, and unhappy.
The monolith that was helping us
to move quickly in the beginning
is now the thing that's
starting to hold us back.
We thought about
rebuilding the application,
but honestly, it's gonna take too long.
We estimate that it's gonna take
at least two years to do this,
and we are not even sure
this is the right approach.
We make changes
in some of the parts of the
application very frequently,
which we can't do at the moment,
but other parts of the application
haven't really changed
since we implemented them.
So, if this, or some of these
issues sound familiar to you,
it's because you're not alone.
These are problems that we
see commonly with customers,
and untangling this mess can
seem like an impossible task.
It's hard to know where to begin.
- [Audience] All right, so (indistinct).
- So, you may be asking yourself:
Why is there a picture of
a tree on screen right now?
Just a quick show of hands,
does anybody actually recognize this tree?
Okay, I see a few hands,
there is a hint in the title.
So this is, in fact,
the strangler fig tree.
It's native to Queensland, Australia,
where I actually grew up.
And this particular strangler
fig tree is actually...
This photo is taken in the
botanical gardens in Brisbane,
and the buildings in the background
are actually the university
that I studied software architecture at
many, many years ago.
Now, these trees are, as you can see,
quite interesting in
terms of how they grow.
They've got quite interesting patterns
with all of these branches or
roots that are coming down,
looks like from the top of the canopy.
And I guess to explore why
these trees look like this,
we need to understand how
they start their lives.
So, the strangler fig tree
is actually a parasitic tree.
So, a bird, or a possum,
or some kind of animal eats its seed,
flies away, finds another tree,
which I'll refer to as
a host tree from now on,
and deposits the seed on
one of the branches up top.
Now, because of the material
that's mixed in with the seed,
it kind of sticks to the branch.
That seed will germinate
and the tree will actually
start to grow from the top down.
So it'll start its life up the top
and kind of wrap itself
around one of the branches.
And then as quickly as possible,
its objective is to get into the soil
so that it can suck up all the nutrients,
which will enable it to grow faster.
So you get this quite interesting pattern,
where these trees are
actually hollow in the center.
So there's a cavity, for
example, in the center there,
and you can actually go in,
kind of move your way through the tree,
and it's actually hollow up the top.
And the reason for this
is because this is not the
tree that was originally there.
Eventually, they'll start to consume
and envelop the entire
host tree and kill it.
But an interesting
benefit for the host tree
is while this is happening,
those roots, all of these
extra rooting points,
are actually providing
more stability to the tree,
the host tree that's being killed.
This is relevant because in Queensland
where these trees live,
severe storms, cyclones,
or hurricanes of Category 5 are common.
In summer, almost every day,
there's severe storms
with very high winds.
And ironically, the strangler fig
is actually providing more
stability to that tree,
the host tree that it's killing
during the period of
time where it's growing.
So it's really helping
the host tree survive
while it's killing it.
So how does this apply to software,
and how can we apply this behavior
of providing the stability
to the existing system
while killing it at the same time?
Now, this is where the
strangler fig pattern comes in.
This is not a new pattern.
This is actually coined by
Martin Fowler back in 2004,
and it's still relevant
in 2025 because it works.
Turns out, that this isn't a
very, very effective pattern.
The core concept
is we want to incrementally
build a new system
on the edges of the existing system.
The focus is really to
do this incrementally.
So focusing on the biggest
problem that we have
and extracting that from the monolith
and building a new component
around the edges of the system.
We can do the same
thing with new features.
So we can start to build
smaller, interdependent systems
around the edges of the
monolith and slowly strangle it.
This gives us a couple of advantages.
Firstly, as we move those
services off the monolith,
we're gonna improve the
stability and the durability
of the monolith itself.
We'll start to solve some of
the problems in the monolith,
and by doing so, the actual...
The monolith is gonna be more stable
and we can start to get
some of that agility back,
but at the same time,
we're also reducing the risk
of the thing falling over.
Okay, so this is the general idea,
but let's actually look at how we do this.
So, this is a typical starting point
for most of our customers.
We've got our monolith, it's
been simplified a little bit,
but just for illustration purposes.
So the whole thing is a problem.
We talked about that,
but the biggest problem we
have is this search service.
It's been there for years.
There's so much duct tape on that thing.
Every time there's any release,
there's always a problem there.
So this is where we're gonna start.
To compound this,
the search is implemented
in a relational database.
That was probably not a good
idea, but it's what we used.
We had a batch process that was running,
and it used to run in about
one minute every hour,
and now it runs for the full
hour, if it completes at all.
So this is thrashing our
monolithic database as well.
So we've decided to start,
but before we get started,
we need to introduce a
component into the design
so that we can make these changes
without having to go into the code
and change the monolith every time.
So the first thing we're gonna do
is implement a facade or a proxy,
and it's gonna sit in between
the users and the application.
This is gonna be used to steer traffic.
So initially, it's just
gonna be a thin routing layer
that's just gonna send all
of the existing requests
from the users of the user interface
straight through to the
monolithic application,
pretty much as its operating state
should be transparent to the
end users and the clients.
But we're gonna start
selectively steering the traffic
based on the new services that we develop
to these new services or to the monolith.
This allows us to make those changes
without having to go back in
and change everything in the monolith
every time we want to
implement new services.
So it gives us a bit more control.
So we've dedicated two sprints
to developing our new search service,
and we're gonna make different
architectural choices
this time.
We are going to have the
service own its own data
because this will allow us
to evolve that service independently
without having a shared data model
that requires us to go back in
and change all of those components
and potentially impact other services.
So this is gonna give
us a bit more agility
to independently develop that service.
We're also gonna use a
purpose-built data structure
that's optimized for search.
So, we're gonna move away
from our using a relational
database for everything model.
And we're gonna reimagine
how we do indexing as well.
We're gonna move to a
constant work pattern,
where we're only incrementally
loading some things in.
So we've made our choices,
we've tested the service,
and everything's looking pretty good.
We're ready to cut over.
So how we do this is
we're actually going to,
in the proxy, go back in, and add a route
to start routing that traffic
to our new modern service.
All the existing requests
will continue to go through
the monolith as usual,
but our new request for
search will be redirected
to our new search service.
So we've taken our first step
towards moving to the monolith,
and we've solved two key problems.
We've taken a significant problem area
in our monolithic
application and removed it.
At this point, this is
just some dead code.
It's not doing anything, we
could go and clean it up,
but we don't really need to.
But we've also alleviated
a lot of the pressure
on our monolithic
database at the same time.
So this one was fairly simple
because it didn't have
too many dependencies
between other components in
the monolithic application.
We've solved some of our
problems, but as I mentioned,
we need to change parts of this
application very frequently,
in particular the article
management service.
We're actively developing
this, or we want to,
if we can get our way out
of fighting fires all day.
So this is where we're gonna
focus next, but as you can see,
there's more interaction
between these components.
So we need to actually
introduce another component
into our design
to help us to be able to
transform this component.
So we're gonna introduce something
that's called an anti-corruption layer.
Now, we could do this differently.
We could go back in and try
and find all of the references
to these internal interfaces
and go and update them in our code,
but as I said,
we'd have to get approval
from all the product managers to do this.
It's gonna be difficult
and it's gonna be difficult
to roll back as well.
Instead, what we're gonna do
is introduce a small
wrapper into our monolith,
and all that's gonna do is
translate the old to the new.
So it's just going to
convert the data formats
and interfaces used by
the old interactions
into the new interactions.
The goal here is really
to minimize the change
to the monolith as much as possible.
So, again, we've taken the same approach,
we've dedicated a couple of sprints
to developing our new service,
we've implemented our anti-corruption
layer in our monolith,
and we're ready to cut over.
So, we follow the same pattern,
we go back into our proxy,
we implement our route,
and we deploy our anti-corruption layer.
Which is gonna forward
any internal interfaces
out to our new modern service.
At this point, we essentially
just written to repeat,
focusing on the biggest problems
or the most important problems to solve,
to give us back that agility
to independently evolve these components
but also to relieve pressure
on the monolith itself
while we're doing this
and give a more cycles
so that we can move towards innovating
instead of fighting fires all day.
By doing it this way,
we reduce a lot of the
risks that would be involved
in just trying to
redevelop the whole system.
We can continue to use this pattern also
to develop new features as well,
and we slowly start to
build those components
around the edges of our existing system.
So we'll quickly go back
to our original application
and see how you can implement this pattern
using AWS services, for example.
So we have our application,
and the first thing we need to do
is we need to insert that proxy.
So for that we're gonna
use Amazon API Gateway
as our strangler fig proxy.
Why API Gateway?
There are other options here.
But from our use case,
the way we do our billing is per request,
so it works pretty well for that.
It scales automatically
and we hate managing reverse proxy fleets.
So, it's serverless and
this is great for us.
So, to start with, we're
just gonna have a pattern
that's just gonna proxy all requests
through to our monolithic application.
Next, we go in and develop
our search service.
So we're gonna make, as I said,
we're gonna make
a couple of different
design decisions this time.
So we're gonna use AWS Lambda
to implement the the front end components
or the the API components.
We're doing that because
we have variable load,
we don't have requests coming in all day,
so this fits pretty well for
our variable use pattern,
and it also allows us to
scale up as we need to
and reduces a lot of
our operational burden
that we have managing
the application today.
We're also gonna use
Amazon OpenSearch Service
for our data store.
The reason for this is
it's much better suited
for our search use case,
and it's gonna allow
us to ship new features
around that search service
and serve our future customer needs.
So again, we're tested extensively,
and we're happy with it.
It's time to cut over.
The next thing we'll do
is we'll add a route into our API gateway
to redirect any search
requests to the new service
and continue to send those through
to our existing application,
the rest of the services.
Now, you might have noticed
that once we've removed
the search service,
we've actually reduced the number of tasks
that are serving the original
monolithic application.
And this is the other
benefit we get by doing this
is as we start to reduce
load on our monolith,
we can actually start to
right size that down as well,
and we get an additional
cost benefit there
as we kind of reduce the
load on that component.
Next, we have our article
management service.
We pretty much take the same approach,
but this time again,
we wanna make different design
decisions here, and we can.
So, we have a slight difference here.
So for our search use case,
we're not gonna migrate any data
from our relational database,
we're just gonna re-index it.
So we didn't necessarily
have to migrate any data,
but with our articles,
we've got like five or six
years worth of articles,
and we do wanna migrate that data.
We've chosen Amazon S3 as the store
for storing our article
data in our new application
because it's pretty effective
for the static content that we have,
it's cost-effective, and it scales well.
We have some metadata,
we're just gonna saw that in DynamoDB,
and we're gonna use AWS
Database Migration Service,
or AWS DMS, to actually do
a heterogeneous migrations
of selective parts of
the database into S3.
This way, we can load just
the article data into S3,
continually synchronize that,
until we're ready to cut over.
So, once we're ready to cut over,
we again go back into our API gateway,
and we implement a new route
for our article service,
and we can use the Lambda integration
to directly integrate with our new service
that we've built around the edges.
So, using this pattern,
we've started to build smaller components
around the edges of our application.
We're able to move a
little bit faster again.
(audience applauding)
We can evolve those
components independently,
and whilst this process does take time,
we're incrementally tackling the problems
that are most important to us.
We're gaining time back, we're
not fighting fires all day,
and we can actually focus
back on our roadmap.
Easy, right?
Well, as I mentioned, every
decision comes with trade-offs.
We move forward with a monolith...
As we move from a monolithic pattern
to a distributed system,
integrating and coordinating
those interactions
between those components
does get more complex.
So, Dirk's gonna dive
into a little bit deeper
into some of the more complex components,
and we'll explore how
we can address those.
- Thank you, Adrian.
It's an interesting journey so far,
and I'm very happy that
I'm part of this journey
as a new Chief Integration
Architect for New Science.
And of course, this
journey cannot stop here.
We need to continue.
Similarly to a lift-and-shift migration,
where you shouldn't stop
after that migration,
but then also modernize your workload,
we also now need to
consider a few other things.
For instance, how to integrate
the number of systems
that we now get
out of that first strangling
the monolith migration,
and then apparently we
also need to understand:
How can we actually manage the interaction
between those systems?
For that, we have a pattern at hand
that is widely known and used.
It is called the Saga pattern,
and it actually comes with two flavors:
choreography and orchestration.
Both of them, however,
built on a workflow and the
execution of that workflow
that manages the interaction
between those systems.
Now, a few months back,
when we showed this to our product team,
they actually liked this a lot
that we gain a lot of flexibility
when we cut our monolith
into several pieces,
and they think, "Okay, guys, from now on,
we can build all those cool
products that we can think of."
Of course, they didn't
look at their price point
on the lower right end
that we can see here
and thought they can leave it to us.
Well, for next case, our product
team for next year, sorry,
our product team has decided
that a new feature of a Premium Tier
is to be the most important feature
of our new science service,
and customers can onboard
to that new feature
and then consume premium content
because they are premium subscribers.
We will have a look at
the onboarding process
for such a premium customer
to discuss the interaction between systems
in our microservices landscape.
As you can think, there
is a number of steps
that needs to be fulfilled to
do that onboarding process.
Don't look at that in detail
just to illustrate there's
a ton of work to be done,
and then of course the product team
cannot get away for free from this.
They need to make up their mind
about a few business decisions.
But to understand that flow
and use case a little bit better,
let's pour it into a diagram.
So what we intend to do
is that our end user clients
can be used by our customers
to submit that request to
subscribe to a Premium Tier,
and it'll land in the
subscription management service.
We will make it asynchronous
so that the user directly
receives a response.
And we take care
about the actual subscription
onboarding process
under the hood.
Now, since we now have
a landscape of systems
under the hood,
the subscription management service
is not gonna do everything on its own.
It's gonna employ a lot
of downstream systems
that contribute to the overall workflow.
And one of the most important ones for us
because we want to earn money
is that we try to get some money
from our onboarding customer,
but then we also need to
enable that premium content,
make it available for the new customer.
And last but not least,
we want to add some customer
relationship goodies,
like subscribe them to
a premium newsletter
and onboard them also
to a loyalty service.
And maybe you can also already think of
that we want to have a
certain order of this in place
so that we can make sure
we first get the money
before we do everything else.
Now, the fundamental question
before we even think about:
How can we manage the
interaction between systems?
Is that we need to make up our minds
how we do the integration
between the systems.
And even one step back,
we also need to make up our mind about:
What do we actually
want to build ourselves,
and what do we leave to others
that maybe do it better?
For instance, a payment service.
I don't want to build this on my own,
I don't wanna undergo
through a PCI certification.
I would leave that to somebody
who does this for a living.
And the loyalty service and
also a newsletter service
that are assets that we have to have,
but they don't really distinguish
us from our competitors,
so we also make use of a third
party SaaS service for that.
All right, so with that
upfront, we can now discuss,
"Hey, how do we actually want
to integrate our systems?"
Our goal should be, in that context,
to make the integration as loosely coupled
and simple as possible
for added flexibility
and also to make the overall
app as resilient as possible.
How could we do that?
Well, probably most of
you would, by default,
when it comes to integrating systems,
think about the synchronous
request response model
to use with APIs.
Why is that so?
Because probably most of us
have used synchronous request response
all of their professional life,
with programming languages
when we call procedures or functions,
and we also do the same
when we consume a
website with our browser.
So that seems quite
natural, unfortunately.
It introduces a lot of coupling
to our overall architecture,
and particularly runtime coupling.
So temporal coupling.
Because when a request is running
through this entire network here,
you will bind resources on all stages,
and it can unfortunately then violate
one of the major promises
of microservices.
One of those promises is
that you can scale out
and scale in every service individually.
Well, you can still do this,
but you might be forced to
scale out an upstream system
because just...
Just because a downstream
system is in a struggle,
and this is not what we
want to do, obviously.
So, and even if it happens,
that one of those downstream
systems comes into a struggle,
it may also jeopardize upstream systems
and bring the stability
of your overall app
into not the best shape.
So, the natural next step for that
would be to transform this integration
from synchronous into
asynchronous request response.
This reduces a lot of
our temporal coupling
or runtime coupling,
because now an upstream system
just sends down a POST request
to a downstream system,
and that downstream system
immediately responds with 202 accepted,
as we have seen in the communication
with the end user client,
and then you don't have that
runtime coupling anymore.
There's still a very important
dependency left, however,
which is the availability dependency.
You cannot send a request
to a downstream system using an API
if that downstream system
is not ready to receive that request.
If it's not online or if
it's currently in a struggle,
if it responds with increased error rates.
And this is where message queues help you
because message queues have
the very helpful ability
to buffer messages,
and that means even if one
of those downstream systems
is currently in a struggle
and might not be able to directly
respond to an API request,
the message queue buffers it
and the downstream system
can consume those messages
when it is ready again.
Also, it's quite handy
for a scale-out scenario
because it has the
point-to-point characteristic
that means every message in the queue
is delivered to one process
on the consumer side.
You can just add more processes
to handle more load on those messages.
This is why you can call a message
also a buffering load balancer balancer.
So that's quite helpful.
Apparently,
you shift a lot of
operational responsibility now
to your messaging system.
That means you should
probably want to have one
that is highly available,
scalable, and reliable.
And this is why I typically recommend
to go with Amazon SQS, in this case,
as a cloud native
serverless messaging system.
Fun fact here, in Prime Day 2025,
at peak times Amazon SQS
has managed 166 million
messages per second.
So, it's quite scalable, for sure.
If you're bound to
industry-standard protocols,
like JMS or MQP, you can
fall back to Amazon MQ,
which provides managed
Apache ActiveMQ or RabbitMQ.
So that's quite good already.
However, our diagram is
a bit busy still, right?
We have a lot of channels here.
Maybe we can reduce that a little bit,
and in fact we can.
We can add now published
subscribe channels in some places,
instead of the queues.
What does that help us?
So the characteristic with
publish subscribe channels,
also known as topics,
is that every subscriber
on the right-hand side
receives every of those messages
that a producer on the
left-hand side sense.
So, in this case, the
subscription management service
only needs to send one downstream message
compared to three previously.
That simplifies it a little bit,
and since we're at it,
we can also replace the return channel
from a queue with a topic.
So, that's also a good simplification
and the other positive
aspect that it brings to us
is that if an additional service
should eventually push up,
it can just subscribe to that topic, too,
and can start receiving the messages.
The subscription management
service, for instance,
doesn't have to be changed at all
because it's all in the
responsibility of the subscribers.
Again, the operational responsibility
is something you shift
on the messaging system,
and I would again recommend
to go with Amazon Simple
Notification Service
as a cloud native serverless service
or you can also fall back to Amazon MQ
because Apache ActiveMQ and RabbitMQ
also support subchannels.
Now, you might ask, "Hey, Dirk,
you have introduced queues
for additional resilience and reliability.
Now, you have cut out those queues.
Again, why are you doing
this in the first place?"
Well, I wouldn't cut out the
queues just conceptually.
We have now focused on
publish subscribe channels,
but I always recommend to
use the best of both worlds
and apply the
topic-queue-chaining pattern.
So you can still add a queue
in front of that subscriber system
to have that characteristic
of queues to buffer messages
and also to be able to scale
out on the consumer side.
Okay, so it gets simpler and simpler,
and now maybe we can
even make it more simple,
and maybe we can also forget
about our beloved request response model.
Maybe we can start thinking in events
and we see introduction of our topics,
publish subscribe channels,
we actually provided the precondition
to stop sending requests
or commands downstream.
Now, we can send events downstream
and we can make the messaging
infrastructure also simpler
when we just replace all
those messaging channels
with one message bus.
You will see two icons
that are labeled with bus,
but it's actually the same instance.
It just appears like that
to keep the visualization of
the different layers up here.
And if we want to drive it to the extreme,
we can also put a little
tiny piece of proxy component
in front of our third-party
service providers
to make the event-driven experience
to put it down to the lowest
level of our architecture here.
And those proxies can be
simple lambda functions
that just handle the HTTP traffic
between us and those
third-party service providers.
Again, you wanna have a reliable
and available service for that.
The recommendation would
be Amazon EventBridge
as a serverless cloud native
message bus implementation.
So, that's a quite simplification
of our integration architecture.
And guess what, with that,
we have naturally
provided the preconditions
to now think about Saga choreography
because everything we
need is now in place.
The idea of Saga choreography
is that that workflow
that we talked about in the beginning
is distributed over all
those involved parties,
and each of those parties
is listening to an event
that is relevant to do some processing,
and then each party does some processing
and sends out another event,
publishes a notification that
certain things have happened.
How can that look in concrete
details with our use case?
So, we have the subscription
management service
that is being touched
by the end user client,
it receives the subscription request.
What it can do now is to publish an event,
type is tier upgrade requested.
It goes into the bus,
and what we have as the next
level of downstream systems
are probably the systems that
are interested in this event,
and they can now do some work,
some sanity checks, some
pre-work, and so on,
and they will probably emit
and publish events on their own
and other downstream
systems are interested.
For instance, the payment
management service
can prepare everything
internally for the payment,
maybe add some database
records, and so on,
and then send out a
customer-payment-requested event.
Similarly to the customer
relationship service
that can prepare everything
for the status update of the customer
and then send out an event that
the status has been updated,
and maybe some downstream systems
are interested in doing
more work in that respect.
As we can see here, for instance,
the customer-payment-requested
event seems to be interesting
for the fraud detection service
and the proxy for our
payment service provider.
And in the same way,
the proxies for the
loyalty service provider
and the newsletter service provider
are interested in that
customer status update event.
Now, those downstream
systems do their work,
and they come back with a
past or failed event, maybe.
And what you can see here already
is that we would actually
want to have a timing
or a condition between those two.
We would want to do the fraud detection
before we actually trigger
the payment collection.
So, you can already keep that in mind.
This is something that
is not out-of-the-box
conceptually supported by
the choreography pattern.
And the other systems
downstream also do their work
and publish afterwards
status update events alike.
Now, one of those downstream services,
in this case the payment
management service,
is certainly interested in those events
that stem from those
detailed service downstream
in the same way as the
customer relationship service
interested in learning about those events
that come from the loyalty service
and the newsletter service.
That will certainly trigger
some status updates also
in their systems of records,
and then they provide
updates again into the bus
about the overall progress of the status,
and the subscription management service
will be interested in those events,
because after all,
it needs to be able to
provide a status update
to the customer.
Now, while it might look, at first glance,
still like request response
because things in this
visualization went down
and other things went back again,
it is an important difference here
that we are only sending events.
So, we are not sending commands.
An upstream service is
not sending a command
with the expectation
that a certain downstream
system is doing a certain thing.
It just notifies about it.
There is obviously the
expectation that eventually,
it can see that something
has changed here or there
to provide a status update,
but there is no obvious
command to an obvious target
because that would again, by its own,
apply tight coupling into our
overall architecture again.
With that in mind, we
can have a quick look
at the benefits and challenges
that we see in the Saga
choreography pattern,
and obviously it is quite easy to start.
We came to the conclusion quite naturally
or to our integration architecture setup.
It's really...
It really supports also autonomous teams
that every service that is involved here
can still work individually
and it also provides you with high scale.
The challenges, however,
is the fact that the
workflow is distributed
across all those parties
and encode it there
makes it really tough to grasp it.
And it might be well-documented
in the very beginning,
but everybody knows it.
Over time,
people will inject more
event types into the system,
and then you might end up
with that big ball of mud.
Also, if you want to change the workflow,
you will always have to touch
either code, or configuration,
or both of the involved systems.
Now, maybe there's an opportunity
to externalize that workflow
and make it better visible.
Yes, there is,
and this is where Saga
orchestration comes into action
because the idea of Saga orchestration
is to make that workflow
externally available and explicit.
To illustrate this, let's
only look at the first half
or the first 2/3 of this diagram now,
the subscription management service
and the first downstream services.
How can we externalize that
using an orchestrator now?
Now, we can think about the workflow,
how we would want to have it.
The subscription management service
would actually launch such a workflow.
It would call the payment
management services API
called initiate a payment,
and then there's a condition check.
Was that actually successful?
If no, then we go back
to the subscription management service
and let it send a
notification about a failure
to the end user.
But maybe it was successful,
and hopefully that is the
case most of the time.
Then, we can continue, we
can unblock the content.
If that was not successful,
we would provide a refund to the customer
for the time being.
In the future, maybe we will
make it more comprehensive,
but for now, that is
how we are gonna start.
If the unblocking of the
content was successful,
we can also use the customer
relationship management service
to initiate the provisioning
of the newsletter subscription
and the loyalty program onboarding.
If that wasn't successful,
currently our agreement
with those service providers
is that we do a manual intervention,
and then we can notify the
customer of partial success.
If that was successful,
we can notify full
success to our customers.
Okay, so while it might be
fun to draw this on a slide,
you need to implement and
actually execute this, right?
So this is where AWS Step
Functions comes into action,
which is, again, a
managed serverless service
that is made exactly for such things:
to execute workflows at scale.
And you can redraw literally
the same thing also
in the AWS Step Functions
management console,
where it would look like that.
If you want to take a
picture, you can do it now.
Right.
So, what are the benefits and
challenges of orchestration?
So the main benefit, obviously,
is that you make this workflow explicit,
and that also makes it
easier to evolve the workflow
and also to find error solutions
or uncover error situations
and make sure that
everything is consistent
because the executor
also keeps state of it.
Apparently, you introduce
a new component here,
and that should be highly
available and highly scalable.
And I also want to stress the last point
on the challenges aside,
that you actually need
to couple this workflow
a little bit to the implementation details
of the involved parties.
So that brings us to the conclusion
of when to use what.
In the end, it's quite simple.
You use choreography when
the benefits of choreography
outweigh the challenges
for you personally,
or you use orchestration
when the benefits of orchestration
have more importance for you
than the challenges to have.
My personal recommendation,
however, is you use both.
You can actually combine both approaches
in the same architecture.
In our example use case,
I would use orchestration
for everything that is related to payment
and content unblocking,
and I would use choreography
for everything that is related
to customer relationship management.
So, that's all good.
I have one problem left, Robert,
and I hope you can help me.
So with those third
party downstream systems,
they give us often a hard time,
like they are moody on Monday mornings,
particularly the payment service provider,
and we don't seem to
treat them well either.
So, maybe you have a solution for that.
- Let's have a look at that, Dirk, gladly.
So looking at our current situation,
we should have every reason to celebrate.
We have this very nice
new subscription workflow
with a Saga pattern,
and our customers love
our premium content.
They are practically lining
up to become paid subscribers.
The issue is our subscription team
is not having a good time, regardless.
How come?
Well, as Dirk already mentioned,
we have some downstream APIs
that can be a little bit moody.
Some of them,
maybe we are at fault because
we are also overloading them.
And when that is happening,
the Saga pattern is kicking in,
and it rolls back the whole
distributed transaction
with all of the involved
parties that have set up,
and that is good.
And after some time, we can
retry this whole operation,
and if it succeeds, that's fine,
but if it fails again, we
have to roll back again.
And if we do that multiple
times, if we retry and fall back,
and retry and fall back,
we are adding so many
remediating API calls
that undo any state changes
that have happened in
the downstream systems
that we are also overloading APIs
that used to work perfectly fine for us.
So, we are cascading the issue
and making everything worse for ourselves.
How do we handle this?
Let's compare it to a real-world example.
Where do you have an overload
situation in your home?
For example, in your electrical system,
if your electrical system
at home is overloaded,
you have a circuit breaker that trips,
and this is saving your
appliances from being damaged.
It also protects your wiring.
It might even protect your
home from fire breaking out.
And the cool thing
about the circuit breaker
system at your home
is if this is happening in the kitchen,
most likely all of your
appliances in your bedroom,
in your bathroom, et cetera,
still run fine because only
the circuit of the kitchen
is affected in this moment.
So the issue at hand
is isolated, contained,
and can be safely dealt with.
Wouldn't it be nice if
we had a similar thing
for our distributed systems
that we are handling?
And as luck would have it,
we have a pattern for this,
and aptly it is also named
the circuit breaker pattern.
A circuit breaker is operating
in two primary states,
that is the good closed
state and the bad open state.
Please do remember that
because it is a little
bit counterintuitive.
Normally, we associate
something being closed with,
"Oh, this is blocking our progress.
We cannot continue doing what we want."
However, for a circuit,
the closed state is the only one
where current can successfully flow.
An open circuit is a broken circuit.
So, our normal state is a closed circuit
with normal operation.
If we get too many errors here, however,
this flips over and
trips into the open state
and we stop operations.
In our physical example,
now somebody would need
to go to the kitchen,
check the different appliances,
find the culprit, disconnect
it, remediate the situation,
a very binary and manual process.
In our integration pattern, however,
we can do something more clever.
We introduce a third
state, the half open state.
This half open state kicks in
after a little bit of time has
elapsed that you configure,
and we just try a few operations,
and we see if they succeed
or if they continue failing.
If they fail, we know the
system isn't ready yet.
We can't continue,
we go back to the open state,
and we wait for another time to pass,
and we try the half open processing again.
However, if our executions are successful,
we hit the success threshold,
and we go to the closed state
and continue our normal operation.
How would it look like to
protect a single execution
with this circuit breaker pattern?
Let's have a look here.
First of all, I need to know
at the start of my execution,
what is the state of the circuit?
Is it open or is it closed?
So I need to have that
information stored somewhere,
have a circuit status
store that I'm checking.
Then, I decide very binary.
Is my circuit closed, yes or no?
If it is not closed, so if it's open,
the bad state, I don't continue.
I don't want to overwhelm
the system even more.
I stop at that point
and I might retry later.
However, if the circuit is closed,
I execute my business logic
and I hope that it now is successful.
If it is, all is done,
all is fine, we end here.
If the business logic fails at this point,
I will record the failing,
I will increase a failure counter
that if it reaches my
configured threshold,
opens the circuit,
and stops further
operations from happening.
A key message here is that this
is not a theoretical process
that I'm showing you here.
Exactly, this process is something
that our customers are
implementing, again,
with AWS Step Functions to
protect their executions
with a circuit breaker pattern.
Right, knowing this now,
let's get back to our story.
We have a lot of business success,
we have a lot of customer
interest coming in,
but it is all at risk because
of the technical failures
that are happening downstream.
What do we do in this
situation as a proper company?
We have a crisis meeting, of course.
We have the subscription crisis meeting,
and here, our obsolete is
kicking it off and is saying,
"Well, the thing keeps failing
at different points under high load.
Sometimes, it's this API.
Sometimes, it's that.
Sometimes, it's a timeout
or it fails outright.
Things are not working properly."
Immediately, our CFO is
leaning forward and is saying,
"In our current growth phase
with this customer interest,
this is not acceptable.
We need these subscriptions to come in,
we need the payments to continue growing."
The always helpful architects are saying,
"Well, what about we store
the subscription intent,
but we do not process them
if the system is overloaded.
What if we do just that?"
To which the user
experience leaders saying,
"Well, we cannot do that silently
because our customers will
just continue retrying,
and retrying,
and maybe their credit card
gets charged multiple times,
they will hate that our
support will be overloaded."
And finally, the poor on-call guy
who has been dealing with
this the whole weekend already
is just tired of hitting F5
in the monitoring system all the time
and trying, five minutes
after five minutes,
new executions until
everything works again.
So, he just wants to be done with this.
As you see, the situation
is quite chaotic,
like the speech bubbles
on this slide here,
but let's have a look how we
can step by step resolve this
with an event-driven pattern on AWS.
First of all, the concern of the obsolete.
The thing keeps failing,
and here you see the
subscription state machine
that we have set up,
and what we can do is to
configure a CloudWatch alarm
that triggers after a certain threshold
of failed executions is being triggered.
That is our detection mechanism here.
Next, the CFO wants the business running.
So this, in the middle, is our happy path.
What usually happens in our application,
we get a subscription
intent from a customer
via an HTTP POST request from API gateway.
This is being persisted
in an Amazon SQS queue,
and when we have a closed circuit,
there is an EventBridge pipe
that is forwarding the
intent into the step function
that is processing the subscription for us
with all of the downstream systems.
So, this is the good path
that the CFO wants to have happening.
However, if we do have errors,
the architect was saying,
"Well, let's just pause the execution."
And the good thing is a CloudWatch alarm
is always publishing state changes
to an EventBridge event bus.
So, when it goes into the alarm state,
when it reaches the failure threshold,
it publishes an event there,
to which we can subscribe with a rule,
and that rule could trigger
a different step function
that could stop the EventBridge pipe
between the subscription intent queue
and the actual subscription
execution step function.
So at this point, we
have opened the circuit,
nothing is going on,
but we are not losing subscription intents
because they are stored and persisted
in the SQS queue coming in.
The concern of user experience
was we need to inform
our users about this.
So, we could also add this purpose
to the step function that
we just introduced and say,
"This step function can
additionally change a parameter
in parameter store,
which is signaling that we
have a processing delay,"
and this information we make available
via the API gateway as an endpoint,
which gives our front and
team the possibility now
to have a warning box there.
"Hey, we are under heavy load,
we have received your subscription intent,
but it might take a while
until we get to process it.
Don't retry all the time."
And the on-call guy, finally really tired,
he just wants to sleep,
he doesn't want to do
something every five minutes,
so let's automate that for him.
We can have an EventBridge schedule
that is executing every five minutes
a lambda function, for example,
and that lambda function
gets some test messages
out of the subscription intent queue.
And these test messages for itself,
it is executing against our
subscription state machine.
And if all of these
executions are successful,
we can start the pipe again
between the subscription intent queue
and the subscription
execution state machine.
So, you might not say, "Robert,
this is all fine and well,
but you have painted so many
icons here and so many errors.
Isn't this extremely complicated
and a mess to maintain?"
To which personally I would say,
"It's rather structured, actually."
Because if we layer on
top the different states
of our circuit breaker
that we discussed about,
then you see on the very top
you have this half open state
that is just testing
whether something works
again and executing it.
In the middle you have the
happy path, the closed state,
and on the bottom are the components
that are acting when we have
an error and an open state.
So, this is rather structured
and maintainable still
for the parts that they represent.
Now, this can solve our challenge at hand,
but it might be a little bit drastic,
especially if our main problem
is that we are overloading some
third-party APIs downstream
just stopping our subscription
workflow completely,
and have some
not-that-nice-looking error message
towards our customers is
not the best signal, maybe.
So, can we do something differently,
something more targeted for this situation
of overloading APIs?
And of course, we can.
This is where rate limiting comes in
and it's all about
consuming APIs responsibly,
being a good API citizen.
Usually, you have a
relationship and a contract
with your third-party
API provider that says,
"You are allowed to
execute X many API calls
per minute, for example,
and anything more,
we will either block you
or they will just fail."
You can handle the situation
in two different scenarios differently.
First of all, you might have APIs,
where you do not really care
what the return body is of the API.
You just sent messages somewhere
and you need to know that
the HTTP call was successful,
but you don't need the body
of the request response coming back.
For this, the pattern would
be rather straightforward.
You could just have an API
execution intent, again,
being persisted in an SQS queue,
which has an EventBridge pipe
that we talked about before.
And this EventBridge pipe
is configured with an API destination,
which is a feature of EventBridge,
which conveniently has max invocations
per seconds parameter.
So, this is doing the throttling for you
and you do not violate
any of your agreements,
but it is more for a
fire-and-forget situation
where you're not
interested in the results.
The other situation that
might even be more common
is that you do need the
response of a request
because you need to decide how to react,
depending on what you
get back as a response,
there might be a decision to be made.
For example, the fraud
check that we have seen.
If a customer is known to be a fraudster,
you probably don't want to continue
your subscription process with them.
For that, we have a different pattern
that is not too dissimilar
to the general circuit breaker pattern
that we talked about before.
But instead of having a counter
where you have the error threshold
that is going up if something is failing,
you maintain a bucket of request tokens
that are available to you.
You need to define a little bit of logic.
How often am I allowed to
execute that API in what time?
But if you have the logic for that,
you could use DynamoDB
to protocol your requests
and calculate,
"At this moment, where I
want execute something,
do I still have capacity left?"
If you do not have capacity left,
then you can just go into a wait task,
and let's say, after five minutes,
retry again and check again.
Do I have any tokens available to me?
If you do have a token available, however,
you reserve one of these tokens.
So your protocol that you
are executing this API now
to adhere to your contract,
and then you are executing an HTTP task
in AWS Step Functions,
which will give you back the response body
that you can then make decisions upon.
So very similar to the
circuit breaker pattern itself
and can help you in this situation.
Knowing how we can be a
responsible API citizen
and not overwhelm downstream APIs,
can we rely on everybody
also respecting our boundaries
out in the internet?
Well, of course, we cannot.
And this is why you also need
to protect your own APIs.
This is something that
we also want to go into.
If I mention protecting APIs,
the first service that many
people will think about
is AWS Web Application Firewall, the WAF.
And indeed, you can, of
course, protect your APIs
with the Web Application
Firewall from overloading.
And here, you can react
with counting the requests
to just get a picture of
what is happening currently,
blocking any requests
that are being too much,
or challenging them with
a capture, for example.
And you can do that on a
five-minute sliding window.
This is very important to remember.
You're not very flexible
with the timing here.
It's always the five-minute
window that you are going.
But you can scope it very flexibly.
You can look at the IP,
the path, the header,
and a combination of
all of these to decide,
"This is now too many requests
coming from that source."
In many cases,
you will, however, know
who your counterpart is
or you will want to know.
And here, you can use
the Amazon API Gateway
with its usage plans and API keys.
This is exclusive to the
REST flavor of API gateway,
not available for HTTP.
And here, you hand out API keys.
Important to never use API keys
for authentication and security.
This is just for
identification and tracking,
so you still need a proper
authentication mechanism.
But you can associate usage
plans to your API keys
that define how often may your
customer execute your APIs
in what timeframe.
This is one possibility.
The other thing is you can
also configure throttling
on the API gateway in general.
You can do that on all APIs
in the region or per route.
And if you want to be more granular,
you can do it on the API
stage and method level,
but only for the REST flavor again.
Coming back to this very important message
that we also started the talk with,
you have to do some decisions.
We gave you some options,
some patterns that you can work with here.
It's not a full list at all,
but we hope that you have
more tools in your belt now
to handle these situations.
Coming to the actions part,
the first action that I want you to do
is to take your phones out
because there will be a
little bit of information
for you to retain.
First is we have curated
a list of other sessions
that you might be interested
in that go into similar topics
or do deep dive on ones that
we brought up right now.
So, please take a picture
if you're interested.
And the next picture opportunity
is on the next slide
that I'm going now to,
which is this QR code,
which will lead you to a website,
where we have curated further resources
where you will find slides
and also our contact information
if you want to discuss further.
Talking about discussing further,
this is a silent session,
so we cannot be too loudy in the room,
but the three of us will
be outside of the room
and happy to take any questions.
With that, thank you
all so much for coming,
especially during lunchtime.
It's been a pleasure.